still face significant challenges
people are being told to stay at home
businesses are still closed
it's going to take us a long time to
fully recover
from the damage coronavirus has done to
our economy
today's budget is a three-part plan
to protect the jobs and livelihoods of
the british people
the first part is this we're going to
keep
economic support in place until well
past the point
that we exit lockdown the furlough
scheme
support for the self-employed business
grants business rates holidays
tax cuts and the temporary universal
credit uplift
have all been extended and generously
taken together this year and next
we're spending 407 billion pounds
to support people and businesses through
coronavirus
i said whatever it takes
and that means for however long it takes
but that unprecedented level of support
combined with the damage coronavirus has
done places huge strain
on our public finances simply put
we have to get borrowing and debt back
under control so the second part of
today's budget
begins fixing that now some people
think we should ignore this problem or
worse there are some who think there is
no problem at all
but i think that's wrong if we don't act
once the economy has recovered to
control our borrowing
we won't be able to fund the stronger
public services people want to see
and when the next crisis comes along we
won't be able to respond
with the boldness we have this time
so i want to be honest with you now
today
about how we'll begin fixing the public
finances
the choice i've made is as much as i can
to protect working people small
businesses
and public services and so
while i have chosen to freeze personal
tax thresholds
some of the most generous in the world i
am not going to
increase the rates of income tax
national insurance
or vat and i am not going to find the
money that we need
by taking it from public services like
schools
or the nhs freezing tax thresholds
is fair asking more of those
on higher incomes and we're going to ask
large businesses who have made a profit
to contribute as well two years from now
well past our recovery in 2023
corporation tax on company profits
will increase to 25 percent
the united kingdom will still have a
lower corporate tax rate
than the united states japan canada
france italy and germany
and we're protecting small businesses by
keeping their corporation tax
at the current rate of 19
this means seven in ten businesses
will see no tax increase at all
only the largest most successful
companies
will pay the new higher rate and they
can now plan
with certainty i know the british people
don't like tax rises
nor do i but i also know
they dislike dishonesty even more
that's why i've been honest with you
about the problem we have
and our plan to fix it
so right now we're going long extending
our support for people and businesses
well beyond the end of lockdown and
while it is important
to control borrowing and debt those
measures
only take effect after the economy has
recovered
but today's budget is not just about
fixing problems
today's budget is also about laying the
foundations
of our future economy we're building our
future economy
by doing things that haven't been done
before and doing them for
everyone everywhere our success with the
vaccine
has shown us this country can be a
scientific
superpower leading the world through the
coming technological and scientific
revolutions
towards a future where growth and jobs
go hand in hand with tackling climate
change
where we are known around the world as
the best place to invest
and do business and where we redraw the
economic map
with decent jobs in every corner of our
country
to do that this budget is helping people
develop new skills start an
apprenticeship
and get better paid jobs this budget is
helping small business owners
get the training skills and technology
they need to compete with bigger firms
and become the high growth companies of
the future
and this budget is bringing prosperity
to the whole
united kingdom with new free ports
around the country
and the largest pro-investment tax cut
in modern british history making the
time to invest right now
and the place to invest right here
so that is our budget our plan
our numbers but the number that in so
many ways
defines the last 12 months is not
included
in today's budget document
i want to finish my remarks by
acknowledging all those
who have lost their lives to coronavirus
to the family and friends left behind
your loss felt most acutely in the
quietest of moments
must be overwhelming
but i promise you we will meet this
moment
with the passion and energy it demands
and we will build a fairer and more just
country
in their memory our recovery
begins today
thank you i think we have some questions
from both public and journalists so
maybe we could turn to the first
question chancellor how will the new
budget ensure that leaseholders
aren't burdened with unfair costs
associated with cladding
and other historical building defects
robbie hi thank you for your question
now
with regard to i wonder if you're
particularly impacted by this in which
case if you are i'm sorry because i know
this has been
enormously frustrating and worrying for
people and what we did
is take action a little while ago and
made some announcements
to help people who are dealing with
unsafe cladding
in their buildings i became chancellor a
year ago in the first budget last year i
announced an extra billion pounds
and a few weeks ago the government
announced an additional three and a half
billion pounds bringing the total
that we will spend to five billion
pounds to help remediate
unsafe cladding from buildings over 18
meters
which are the most unsafe and that work
is already underway
and we're getting on with that at pace
we also know there are people in other
buildings who might also want to have
remediation work done
so what we're doing there for those
smaller buildings is providing a
government-backed loan scheme
which will provide low-cost
government-backed loans to people
which will be capped at no more than 50
pounds a month
so that will help provide funds to deal
with those buildings
and also we know that there have been
some problems with the mortgage market
and people asking for particular forms
so we're working very hard the housing
secretary the prime minister and i
with mortgage lenders and the industry
to make sure that the use of those forms
they're called ews one forms
that have been causing the issue the use
of those forms is going to be
proportionate
and we really hope that will help
unblock the market together
uh with a government insurance scheme
that we're providing for people who do
those assessments
so i think the combination of five
billion pounds of funding to remedy to
remediate the most unsafe buildings
a cheap government loan to help with the
rest and these interactions
interventions on the mortgage market
when you put them all together
hopefully they will make an enormous
difference and provide reassurance to
people
through what i know has been a difficult
process
so next if we could go please
yes uh hello chancellor sizable islam
um chancellor what would you say to the
i think it's million
also people that will enter the income
tax system the million or so people that
will
end up uh in the higher rate
and when you put that together with the
uh rise in corporation tax this is a
turning round of
conservative principles has the pandemic
fundamentally changed the conservative
approach to
big business big borrowing big taxation
and big spending
thanks faisal well hopefully both in the
remarks i made
earlier now and in the house of commons
earlier people will have understood the
logic what we're trying to do
now obviously the pandemic has dealt us
uh
pretty bad damage to the public finances
in the economy and i think
i and the government have a
responsibility to put those on back in a
strong position over time but do that in
a way
that is supportive our economic recovery
in the short term but also do so in a
way that is fair
and i think both of the measures that
we've implemented the ones that you
mentioned
past that test for example that the
threshold freeze
means that those on the lowest incomes
contribute much less than those
on higher incomes and it's something
that only builds over time so it's very
supportive
of our recovery and importantly nobody's
current take-home pay
will be affected as a result of this
policy
what this policy does is mean that in
the future
any benefit that might have come from
thresholds rising with inflation
will not be there and that's what will
help us rebuild our public finances in a
fair
and honest way and i know that's been
supported by several think tanks and
others who have said that's a sensible
thing to do
and with grant a corporation tax we
remain a party that believes in a
government that believes in supporting
business
and which is why our corporation tax
even after this change
will still be the lowest out of the g7
large economies that we
compete with so i think that's something
that we will be proud to do and make
sure that we support business in that
way but also
crucially we will be exempting the vast
majority of businesses are small and
medium-sized businesses
from that increase because we want those
with the bigger shoulders just the
largest most profitable country at
companies
to make the contribution in two years
time and also
there are lots of other things in
today's budget which is supportive of
business
whether that's short-term support with
business rates
holidays vat cuts cash grants
but also new help to grow management and
digital incentives
because we want to help small and
medium-sized businesses get the
management
training they need and help them get the
digital technology they need to compete
in the future economy and so that to me
when you put it all together
are the actions of a government that
firmly believes in supporting business
both in the short term
but also in the long term and the last
thing i'd say because i
i think it's also important we really
want businesses to invest
but we know that investment can help
drive our recovery
and today i announced something called
the super deduction
which is a tax cut for business
investment the likes of which we haven't
ever seen before
in this country and that will really
support businesses to invest now over
the next two years
to help drive our recovery and i think
it will make a huge difference
next are we going to joel
hello there chancellor can you hear me
okay i can joel fire away
i want to pick up on corporation tax the
corporation tax
increase is enormous it's a six point
jump overnight in two years time the
confederation
of british industry describes it as a
worrying signal this does feel like a
gamble doesn't it especially
now brexit is done you say you want more
businesses to invest in the uk
is there a danger that this will achieve
the opposite
well joel i think that the the cbi also
said lots of other positive comments
about the the budget
today which people can can read but you
talk about the corporation tax rate
again and you talk about international
competitiveness and the signal it sends
we will still have a lower corporation
tax rate
than any of our major g7 competitors
so america canada france germany italy
for example and so i think that puts us
in very good stead internationally
and if you broaden that group of large
economies out to another group called
the g20
were the 20 largest economies in the
world we would still have the fifth
lowest rate in that group
so i think on any measure it's still an
internationally competitive rate that
signals
uh that britain is is open for business
and supportive
of business and as i was saying to
faisal the super deduction
the tax cut for business that we've put
in place over the next two years to
support the recovery
to drive up business investment in new
factories new machines
across the country that's an enormous
tax cut for business
i think it's the biggest business tax
cut that i think we've ever seen in
british history as far as we can
calculate
but i think that shows we're on the side
of business and we know they can help
play their part in the recovery but i
also think it's reasonable given the
amount of support that we've
given business given the the crisis we
face with our public finances
that it's reasonable to ask those
largest
most successful companies in two years
time to contribute
uh something back to help us rebuild i
think that's a reasonable and fair
approach
that will support us in the long term
but it's reasonable in the
in the long term as well
i think next are we going to ed
yes hello hi chancellor ed conway news
can you can you hear me
and behind me we've got a chart that
we've been looking at a lot
uh today at sky news showing you tax as
a percentage of gdp basically the tax
burden
uh in the uk and i suppose my question
is you know looking at this chart and
looking at how
high the tax burden is getting towards
the end of the forecast horizon
are you concerned about being the
chancellor with the highest
tax burden of any chance of going all
the way back to the 1960s
and roy jenkins does that concern you at
all
well ed i guess what the chart your
chart doesn't show is
all the other chancellors if any of them
have had pandemics to deal with
and you know we haven't had a pandemic
like this in over 100 years
and so i think that's remember that's
why we're having this conversation
that's the problem that we're grappling
with and
unsurprisingly you know when you've had
a shock like that
and then when you've had a response the
one and the likes of which we've done
i think any of those other chancellors
probably have ever had to do as much
fiscal support for
the country as i have had to i i think
it's reasonable to expect that what we
have to do in response to all of those
things is going to be a bit different
to what's happened in the past but what
i would say is
what are we doing what are we doing with
those taxes what we're doing is funding
strong public services
people elected us because we told them
we were the party of public services we
were going to invest in the nhs in
schools
and we were also going to invest in
projects across the country to level up
opportunity
that's what we want to get on and
deliver during this parliament and we
also want to be responsible with the
public finances for the reasons i set
out
and it's because of those reasons that
i've take taken the two decisions i've
made today
and i do believe they are the right
decisions for the country
and for the economy
next we're going to helia
okay that's it
good afternoon chancellor the obr points
out
that in your calculations there's no
provision for
virus-related costs beyond next year
despite the fact that the government
acknowledges that there will be an
annual vaccination program there'll be
further costs
associated with test and trace as well
as of course the nhs increased cost
because of cancelled operations and
procedures
you've made a lot today about wanting to
be honest with people
do you think it's your is it your honest
judgment
today that the pandemic will cost
nothing from next year
on public spending you're right to
differentiate between the
the general plans we have uh which i can
go through in a second and then also the
plans for coronavirus and it's right
think about those things differently now
obviously at this moment
we don't know exactly the future path
of what's going to happen but what we do
know is that this year there's an
enormous amount of call
for extra funding for chronovirus which
is why why today i announced
1.6 billion pounds of extra funding for
example
for the vaccination program to make sure
that we can get that
get that all the resources it needs to
happen as quickly as possible
provide for potential booster shots but
also to improve our preparedness
for future pandemics so some of the
things we're doing is to build that
capacity to react
quickly in the future so i don't have a
crystal ball about about next year but
we are thinking
about the next 12 months and what's
required you talked about nhs backlog
at the spending review in november we
announced billions of pounds of extra
funding
for the nhs both for diagnostic
equipment to
upgrade some of the older diagnostic
equipment and to provide more ability
for the nhs to do elective surgery this
year to start catching up on some of the
backlog that we know exists
but to your broader question about
public services and public spending
the numbers that are set out today show
that there will be strong growth
strong investment in public services not
just over these two years but for the
remainder of the parliament
as well and next
i think catherine sampson yes thank you
chancellor adjust your reaction please
the two points
uh first of all scotland's finance
secretary claims you've not matched her
ambition for supporting economic
recovery and jobs and she's especially
disappointed you didn't make that uplift
to universal credit
and permanence just your reaction to
that and secondly
your business minister suggested an
interview yesterday when it came to an
independence referendum
it was up to the scottish people to
decide when and whether they want one
do you agree with him and is the
treasury planning some change of
strategy here
well catherine i you know i i genuinely
believe that i don't think people want
any of us to be focusing on
constitutional questions at the moment i
think what people want is us to be
focusing on our response
to the pandemic making sure that we get
the vaccine rolled out
as quickly as we can into as many
people's arms as possible
and then with that with the prime
minister's roadmap
cautiously and safely reopen our economy
get our lives back to normal and try and
protect as many jobs as possible
and i think that's actually what people
want us to focus on
which is what we're getting on and doing
with regard to the universal credit
uplift
i announced today that we are extending
that for six months uh this was
something that we put in place
temporarily at the beginning of the
pandemic when we were in lockdown
and the six months extension means that
it will be in place
well beyond the end of this current
lockdown
and it only forms one part of our
response to helping those on low incomes
or those who are vulnerable
there's lots of other things we're doing
helping people with their council tax
bills
with their rental payments through
something called local housing allowance
but crucially the best way to help
people over time
is to give them the skills they need to
get great jobs or get better jobs
which is why we've increased the
national living wage next year
above inflation which means a 350 pound
pay rise for those on low incomes
and we're also with the prime minister's
lifetime skills guarantee for example
giving every adult the opportunity to go
and get a government-funded
qualification
at a good standard which will help them
increase their prospects of getting a
job or getting a new job
and they're doing lots of other things
to encourage companies to hire people
for example our kickstart scheme for
young people or indeed
the 3000 pounds that we're paying
companies to take on a new apprentice
so there's lots of different ways to
help people the figures and the facts in
the document today show that those on
the lowest incomes
have been supported the most by all the
interventions that we've put in place
over the last 12 months so i'm proud of
that
that is this government acting to
protect those who really need our help
but as the economy reopens it's right
that we transition our support to
focusing on people
getting them into work getting them the
skills they need and that's what this
budget delivers
next i think we're going over to the
times
and philip aldrich phillip you there yes
hi
chancellor um uh on
on corporation tax the uh you you're
undoing
10 years of tax policy by
raising corporation tax up to 25 in 2023
uh and you're even reintroducing a small
business tax rate so
i just wondered um was the policy the
previous policy
wrong um and and also what gives you
confidence that your tax rises are not
going to choke off the recovery in 2023
there's still spare capacity under the
obr's forecasts
right at the end of the forecast period
so it looks like
um there's more to go for in in terms of
growth
thanks phil i've been on on i think it's
not right to judge decisions that were
made over the last 10 years
uh by the fact that today we're dealing
with the results of a
hopefully once in a century pandemic
that we're grappling with the decisions
that were made in the past were right
for them
and we're making the right decisions for
now i think with corporation tax over
time
you know what's transpired is it might
not be the most effective way
to drive capital investment up which is
what we want to see because we want
businesses to invest
to create jobs and new machinery to
drive up productivity and
we think our super deduction uh
hopefully will do a better job of that
over the next two years
um and that and i think we'll see we'll
hopefully see the results
of that and then with regard to your
second question
we need obviously to be sensitive about
the timing of this to make sure that we
do support the recovery in the short
term
the super deduction obviously does that
the corporation tax increase doesn't
come for two years
which is past the point that the obr
expect
our gdp to have recovered its pre-crisis
level
uh which actually is is next year in the
second quarter of next year
the bank of england happened to think
that will happen a bit earlier than that
even
and your point on spare capacity you'll
know that that is the output gap which i
think is what you're referring to
is a notoriously difficult thing for
economists to estimate with any
precision
but even on the obr's forecast the bulk
of that gap is closed
over the next 12 to 18 months and then
what's left over the residual period is
i think point one percent from memory
but it i think i think broadly we can
we can safely believe that the economy
will have recovered and that is a safe
time
for the increase to happen but in the
proportionate way uh that it is
not affecting small businesses and
remember corporation tax is a tax
on profits so by definition it's only
those companies who are doing well
making profits
that pay it so
next we're going over to the ft george
are you there hi george i am thank you
chancellor
um can i ask you a bit about your
flagship leveling up
program um we were looking at your one
billion pound towns fund you've
announced today
by our reckoning 40 of the 45 towns on
the list
are represented by conservative mps
we're also looking at the leveling up
fund that you've announced and you've
come up with some priority areas
i noticed that your constituency
richmond shire is in priority area one
whereas places like barnsley bolts over
salford are in priority area
two i just wonder if you give us any
reassurance that you're using
fair criteria to assess the eligibility
of these areas
whether this looks a little bit like
naked barrel politics
thanks george so the formula for the
uh the the the grant payments for the
new
fund to give them some capacity funding
to bid for projects
is based on an index of economic need uh
which is
transparently uh published i think
actually by mhclg
and based on a bunch of objective
measures so that will be there for
people
to have a look at and remember that's
only areas that have received
some capacity funding to bid no area is
excluded for bidding
it's just that those areas on the basis
of this formula might need a bit of
extra help so we're giving those local
areas
some money to put their bid together to
help them uh and
and you know to your broader point i
think if you look at all the things
we're doing they're benefiting people
in every corner of the country so we for
example announced the location of our
eight free ports in england
today you know they're spread in eight
english regions
uh in it from southampton to t side to
liverpool
you know across the country and all of
those areas are actually represented by
a mix
of both mps and local authorities
because what we're interested in is
making sure that wherever you grow up
wherever you happen to live
that this government is helping to
provide opportunity for you
and creating jobs in your area and i
firmly believe that whether it's the
leveling up fund
or our free ports initiative or any
other things we're doing you know we are
delivering and making good on that
promise
next we're going to graham from the
daily mirror graham you there
i am hope you can hear me yes i can hi
good evening hello good afternoon um are
you
chancellor are you prepared to extend
further the cut-off date for the
renewed support that you've announced
today if and while no one wants this the
timing for the roadmap
um has to change and then secondly if i
may what do you say to those who have
labelled it an insult
that there's no pay rise for many
thousands
of public sector workers who've been uh
on the front line during the
june pandemic there's been no pay rise
announced by you today
uh graham to your first point what we've
done very deliberately
is extend all of our support well beyond
the end of the road map which you know
the prime minister set out some dates in
in april march april may and then
finally june
for example look at furlough which is
being extended all the way sept to
september
in line with many other things the
reason we've taken that approach is as i
said in the
in the house of commons today is because
we want to make sure that we've made
allowance for even the most cautious
possible interpretation of the road map
of what might happen
um so we've done that in advance to
provide people with that
certainty uh up front so i think i think
we're well well protected on that and
that i think has been met broadly uh
well today by stakeholders to your
second point on public sector pay
this was something that i addressed in
the spending review
back in november when we talked about
pay for the next year
and back then what i said which i'm
happy to to go over now is
if i when i was looking at all the
numbers what we saw was
in the private sector wages were falling
people were having their hours cut many
of them were furloughed
and sadly almost three-quarters of a
million people in private sector had
lost their jobs
and almost none of those things had
happened in the public sector
so given that and given the obviously
very difficult fiscal situation
situation that we face that we've been
talking about you know i thought for
reasons of fairness
and also to try and protect those public
sector jobs
it was reasonable to take a more
targeted approach to public sector pay
for this next year
so what does that mean that means those
who work in the nhs
a million people it's about a quarter of
all people in the public sector
they will receive a pay rise next year
and we're all very grateful to them
for the fantastic work that they are
doing under difficult conditions
but for everyone else there will be a
pause on pay increases this year
but that means doesn't mean nothing it
means if your pay would normally have
progression built into it as many
contracts do that will still happen and
that's worth about one percent
and then the extra protection we did for
those in the public sector was if
you earn less than about 24 and a half
thousand pounds from memory about the
median
salary of someone in the uk your pay
will also go up by a fixed 250 pounds
or one percent and if you take all of
that together what that means is a
majority of people
in the public sector will see their pay
increase next year
so for the reasons i've set out i think
that is a fair and proportionate
approach
to public sector pay in the
circumstances that we
we find ourselves in and
lastly i think we are going over to ben
from the daily telegraph good evening
ben
can you hear me chancellor i can now
fantastic two quick questions firstly
can you rule out an increase in the rate
of capital gains tax
this parliament and secondly there's
early data that suggests the cobit
vaccine
is having a real impact on the pandemic
a positive impact
quicker than the models suggested do you
think we should be open
to possibly pulling forward some of the
reopening road map dates
if the data says it's safe to do that
thanks ben well i i i always and people
probably tired of hearing me say this
that they've been watching me on the
telly in the recent week but i obviously
can't comment on
fiscal policy other than on the ones
that we're talking about in the budget
so i can't answer your first question
but i think we've made the decisions
we've made on tax and as
uh as we said in our manifesto we didn't
want to raise
the rates of income tax national
insurance and vat
and we have stuck by that uh because
that is important to me
uh to do that and with regard to your
second
uh question um look the prime minister
when he set out the road map
said that what we were trying to do was
for it to be cautious but irreversible
and and that's the right approach and
the dates that we set out were always
the earliest of dates uh we are making
and that's the way they will
remain but it's a good note for us to
finish on
and i think it just to say incredible
congratulations and thanks to everyone
involved
with the vaccine rollout it's been
something that all of us in the country
i think can feel
hugely proud of from the team that
developed the vaccine
in oxford whether it's professor sarah
gilbert and her team you know all the
way to the volunteers who are now
helping get it into people's arms
and shepherding them through all our
vaccine centers an unbelievable rate
faster than almost any other country in
the world
you know what a success story what a
thing for us to be so proud of
and a great advert of what we can be in
the future
we can be as i talked about in the
speech a scientific superpower
where we're developing new medicines new
therapeutics
we can create new companies out of that
create new jobs and spread that
employment around the country
and save people's lives in the process
you know i think it's shown us what
we're capable of a country
and we want to harness that spirit as we
look forward and build a brighter future
for the country as we emerge from this
pandemic and i'm very confident
that today's budget sets us on the road
to doing exactly that
thank you ben and thank you very much
everyone good evening